welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we break
down all the latest movies big game
releases TV shows and comic books this
episode were going to be going over why
a big aspect of the opening of
Terminator Dok fate ruined the entire
franchise didn't make sense and was one
of the worst things to happen in the
entirety of human history second place
only to the birth of Hitler there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
seen terminator dark fate and let's face
it you probably haven't looking at the
box-office then I highly recommend that
you turn off now without the way sit
back shut up this is the intro blah blah
blah let's get into the video okay so
before we get started on this video if
you've never checked out the channel
before then chances are off the intro
you probably think that I'm an [ __ ]
and someone who is really negative about
movies and makes a living from just
tearing them apart and thriving off
negativity because hey the internet
loves drama more than the clintons I
love hitmen
well you'd be wrong on the channel I do
try and talk about movies in a positive
way even if they're mediocre
on the whole though I'm very
enthusiastic about film
I gave parasite a 10 out of 10 yesterday
love the king on Netflix and dr. sleep
all of which I gave big scores to in
fact it's rare that I review something
badly but as a big fan of the Terminator
franchise I just felt like the movie
missed the mark in several ways I've
even went back and rewatched all of the
films from the 1984 original all the way
up to Doc fate just to make sure my love
for them wasn't for nostalgic reasons
and make sure that the 25,000 reviewers
that said this is the best terminal a
sequel since t2 were indeed wrong and
yet turns out they are because salvation
is definitely the best sequel don't at
me anyway you're probably also thinking
and this guy loves the smell of his own
thoughts which may be true but I also
have a lot of love for the Terminator
franchise
I bought t2 on VHS DVD blu-ray then the
ultimate cut on blu-ray
then the 4k transfer that makes everyone
look like
no and yeah I've spent a lot of money
and time on this franchise everything
about Terminator 2 to me is amazing the
effects still hold up the action is
non-stop and the ending doesn't leave a
dry eye in the house so naturally when I
heard that Terminator dark fate was
going to be a direct sequel to
Terminator 2 I was pretty stoked this
was a chance to right the wrongs of the
past and binding at the franchise back
to being one of the best as like alien
predators and others it had fallen by
the wayside a bit due to middling to
poor sequels here was me wide-eyed going
into the cinema about to receive the
biggest slap in the face since the
doctor mistook it for my ass when I was
born and within the first five minutes
of the movie the love that I'd had for
the franchise my entire life the
anticipation and I had since 1991 had
completely evaporated replaced with a
gut punch that felt pointless
unceremonious and universe ruining let
me set the scene John Connor the savior
of mankind and his mother have finally
defeated Skynet the evil robots from the
future that have hunted them for what
seems like an eternity they are finally
relaxing and then out of nowhere out of
the blue a 400 pound machine walks up
shoots John and then Donald's off to go
and get a girlfriend for some reason I
was pretty shocked but not in a good way
and I think my major problem with the
film is that in this opening not only
does it make the prior two entries
completely pointless but it also
replaces these characters with a
rebranded Skynet and people that we
don't care about so let's get this
straight if John Connor is dead then the
first two films are now complete wastes
of time now I have seen people say that
well they weren't because they actually
managed to stop Skynet okay well that's
cool but then Legion still rose up
anyway so that was completely pointless
and humanity are just doomed to a dark
fate and thus yeah wasted time the
entire message behind the first two
films is that there was no fate but it
seems like whatever way you slice it
this war will always happen one way or
another and thus there's now no need to
get invested in the story line as even
if the savior of humanity managed
to stop the machines they will just
rebrand change their name to something
else and pop up in ten years time
basically what this movie does in its
opening five minutes is run the t1 and
t2 completely pointless and it also
ruins the character arcs going forward
for the foreseeable future
if the savior of mankind can be killed
and another one can just take that place
then there is no reason at all to get
invested in Dany Ramos who from what I
saw in the future didn't do that much
anyway other than create a real-life
version of a whatsapp group if John dies
then there is no true quote-unquote
savior and there is no need to protect
Dany as if she dies in who cares someone
else will be in the future and they can
do the work now at this point I'm just
rambling a bit but the death also
creates a lot of plot holes and things
that don't make sense up until this
point though there had been a couple of
retcons in the Terminator timeline on
the whole it did blow through well and
create the events that created it as we
know Sarah Connor was hunted by a
terminator in the 80s one then went back
to the 90s to kill John with his mother
he managed to stop Skynet however this
was merely delayed and the apocalypse
still happened in Terminator 3 John
fought in the war destroyed Skynet who
in a last-ditch attempt to change things
sent back terminators and thus the cycle
begins again every event relies on the
ones before and after it to happen it's
nice it's tight it's a great timeline
however wiping this timeline in order to
kill John it creates a massive plot hole
that I haven't actually seen anyone
talking about what it basically boils
down to is that John cannot destroy
Skynet that can't happen in order for
things to have worked out the way that
they did
if the timeline was wiped because they
destroyed Skynet then John could never
send back Kyle Reese so he would never
have been born so there would be no
reason for Skynet to send terminators
back to kill him thus this entire scene
could have never happened basically
there is a causality that needs to be in
place for any of the characters to be in
this scene the subtext of the Terminator
franchise was that they could never
really kill John because of the
grandfather paradox if terminators went
back in time and managed to kill him
then there would be no reason to send
them from the future and so on I have
seen many people say that this
because it's an alternate timeline but
yeah sorry that still doesn't make sense
because even in an alternate timeline
that would still be no reason to go back
another big problem I have is that the
opening of dark fate takes place in 1998
in the t2 timeline the apocalypse takes
place in 1997 so why exactly did Skynet
send a terminator back in time to after
the nuclear attacks to kill John again I
brought this up and I have seen some
people say that this Terminator was sent
back to t2 miles and miles away for some
reason however in an interview with
Gizmodo Tim Miller the director says
that the Terminator arrived after the
events of Terminator 2 which if you
don't know is set in 1995 so why send
him back after this when defending
killing John later in the interview
Miller says that Terminator was always
Sarah's story and not John's wrong again
Sarah was the carrier of the future of
mankind
hence why there was such importance for
her to survive the first movie if she
hadn't been John Khan's mother then she
would have no importance at all John
Connor could have had any mother it
didn't matter who she was or who his
father was the entire story of the first
film centered around him being born so
he could save mankind once he's born if
Sarah dies or not it does not matter in
the grand scheme of things as he is
alive and thus can go on to fight in the
future Sarah isn't the one to do that
the fact that John isn't even in the
first film and is still so important it
shows that it is his story Terminator 2
is also definitely his story so yeah
from that statement it's clear Tim
Miller doesn't know what he's talking
about later in the movie Arnold's new
character call says that he knows that
Legion is sending back terminators but
how they were never part of the same
company and are from two totally
different timelines again so yeah this
doesn't make any sense basically
everything from the Terminator to
timeline should not exist at this point
including the Terminator as as Skynet
was either destroyed or it wasn't you
can't have it both ways in conclusion
this death basically ruins everything
that built up to it and completely
devalues everything after it and shows
just how little understand
Tim Miller actually has over the entire
franchise he checked the baby out with
the bathwater to give us a movie that
ends up being two robots talking to each
other about how Danny should just be
handed over yeah that's another bad
scene I don't want to spiral off in the
video here but yeah really bad I just
have so many problems with this film but
the death of John Connor is the one
major thing that stuck with me for a guy
James Cameron who said he was angered
that Newt and Bishop were killed in
alien 3 he sure didn't mind doing it
when he had creative control and it just
shows how much the filmmaker has lost a
grasp of what makes his movies good in
addition to this Tim Miller has really
messed up the supposed planned trilogy
that was meant to come after this as it
would be difficult for fans to be
invested when chances are down the line
even if Danny stops Allegiant a
terminator it could just pop up when
she's chilling at the beach and killer
it makes me think that Tim Miller got
removed from Deadpool 2 for very good
reasons and looking back at his big
success Deadpool that opens so many
doors for him and makes me think that
Ryan Reynolds was actually the reason
that that movie was any good and that
Tim Miller probably wanted to kill
Deadpool off in the first five minutes
the decision to kill John in my opinion
not only reeks of shortsightedness but
also appreciation for the character and
the fans who've invested so much in him
there was no send-off no goodbye just
shot and he's dead I wouldn't have even
minded if there'd been a chase of some
sort on the beat at the beginning or you
know just something to make his death
feel earned
however casting him to the side like
that is like casting aside the entire
franchise there's no respect shown no
celebration of the work and it's just a
shock for the sake of being shocking I'm
glad that the movie bombed and for me
the Terminator franchise ended the way
that the t2 ultimate cut did with John
living a happy life joined by his mother
living in a world where movie studios
don't milk properties dry in order to
lose money on projects that fail who
knows hopefully they'll retcon dog Fae
and we can go back to just seeing John
Connor smiling living a happy life and
that's the video obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on my thoughts so
make sure you leave them in the comment
section below you enjoy this video and
agree with me then
please give a thumbs up and make sure
you check out a more positive breakdown
of the movie parasite which you'll be
linked at the end I go over why the film
is one of the best movies of the air so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you want to come
chat to me after the video then make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which you'll be linked in
the description below we post videos
early there and it's free to join so
hopefully I see you over there after
this we're also giving away a free copy
of the Marvel phase 3 part 1 boxer and
blu-ray which contains Civil War Doctor
Strange homecoming Ragnarok and more and
all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on terminator
Doc Fae in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
and open Ben this shall be shipped out
from then to ever gets the prize it's
the best of luck that everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
were mad into movies
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]